[Music]
america isn't the only country facing
economic pressure and social volatility
from unrestrained immigration
just three years ago europe faced its
own
wave of migrants from africa in the
middle east the german chancellor angela
merkel responded to this by accepting
nearly a million migrants
in a single year adjusted for population
that would be like this country taking
in
4 million in just 12 months three years
after that how has that decision
affected germany and merkel's political
career root canal is the current u.s
ambassador to germany and he joins us
tonight ambassador thanks very much for
coming on
of course thanks for joining tucker so
you're starting to see even figures on
the left john kerry and hillary clinton
most prominently but others
rethinking the political fallout from
merkel's decision to do that
in germany from where you sit what was
the effect
of letting in those migrants well first
of all let's talk about the political
effect
um there was no plan in place
so the policy really fell apart um
chancellor merkel and and many in
germany had big hearts they wanted to do
something
but there wasn't a plan and so even
chancellor merkel now
all these years later has agreed that
there was no plan and therefore
the entire policy kind of fell apart
because it wasn't
implemented with with uh you know
hardcore
security measures and follow-up so from
the political standpoint
next week chancellor merkel is giving up
her chairmanship of the party there are
three other people running
and the top issue one of the top issues
is migration and her handling of
migration so politically i would say
that it really toppled her and has has
forced her now to give up the
chairmanship of a party that she once
ran
with a very strong arm
what's so interesting watching germany
from here is how the german press and
its cultural leaders responded so this
was three years ago and it was
immediately obvious that a lot of
ordinary germans didn't like it
and that it was causing the crime rate
to go up and that it was causing
economic pressure on ordinary germans
but people weren't allowed to say that
for a number of years
in public or am i misreading it no
you're exactly right and i would even go
so far as to say that we still have that
problem here in germany there's still
an overreaction if you complain about
wanting
uh secure borders or just an orderly
process look this is not about
whether or not you have a heart this is
about whether or not you have
a plan and and we in the united states
know
that a million people a year
get u.s citizenship we are very generous
this is not about
not wanting to have immigrants and and
the whole idea
that that the left or the
some on the right even or the media
are somehow mixing up legal immigration
with illegal immigration
is really an outrage and those of us in
public policy positions
have to be able to push back and say
look we're not talking about
legal immigration the united states is
very generous germany has been
very generous this is about whether or
not you have a plan
because not everyone is going to be able
to come
and that's what you have to be able to
say is we must prioritize
what is that number is it a million
people in the united states is it four
million people
uh in in germany um over a number of
years
what is that number because whatever
that number is
it's still going to be too low you're
still going to turn people away
so let's have an orderly process and
figure out how to do
legal immigration and do it the right
way our people
because i think that's what we need the
united states is an honest adult
conversation about what we can afford
what's good for our country
and what the next 100 years looks like
demographically
we can't have that conversation here can
germans have it
look i i think the united states is
having a better conversation
than the germans to be honest this has
largely been controlled by
elites in berlin but normal everyday
people are beginning to say wait a
minute
this policy is not working this is not
about being generous we are very
generous they have
they have a lot of open borders
throughout europe but i would also argue
that the mistakes of germany tucker
have rippled throughout all of europe
because
we've seen in austria for instance with
sebastian kurtz
who came in with a platform to say we
must have
uh security and a set of rules
this is not about not being generous
this is not about not being open to
immigrants but this is about just having
rules and once he established the fact
that he wanted rules sebastian kurtz won
uh in in a very big way and is now
becoming very popular throughout germany
so well some in the media in germany
will try to push this into saying
well you're a radical far right person
the the reality is
is that normal everyday germans and
europeans are clamoring for leaders
who want to have safe and secure borders
in an orderly process
well if they want to create radicals
they should keep lying to the population
because that's what they're going to get
ambassador grinnell thank you very much
great to see you tonight
thanks tucker